the most common type of planet around
other stars is what's called a super
earth
these supers have atmospheres that are
too thick
creating pressures too high to support
life like us so why does our small
planet with this exposed countenance and
relatively thin atmosphere appear to be
so rare a new radical idea suggests the
earth could be a second-generation
planet built from the remains of a
demolition derby between giant rocky
worlds that once dominated the early
solar system
imagine the scene 4.6 billion years ago
the planets in our solar system begin to
form from a vast disk of dust and debris
where the earth sits today a band of
super earths are born vast worlds up to
ten times the mass of the earth and with
thick crushing atmospheres we believe
that this first generation of planets
was driven onto the surface of the young
Sun by the migration of our big bully
and the solar system Jupiter
a few million years after the birth of
the solar system the gravity of the
protoplanetary disk slows to pa'dar down
and it starts to spiral in towards the
Sun as it moves in words
it pushes waves of asteroids and debris
towards the super Earths
the incoming debris disturbs the orbits
of the giant planets some mace mash each
other to pieces others are sent hurtling
into the Sun
once the planetary carnage is over
Jupiter is tugged back out by the
gravity of the newly formed Saturn the
solar system that is left behind is a
place that's depleted in solid material
and gaseous material it's a place where
where debris will coalesce over hundreds
of millions of years into the
terrestrial planets that we have today
planetary building starts over in the
inner solar system but the new planets
feed on scraps growing much smaller than
their predecessors with thinner
atmospheres and lower pressures among
them is our own planet the earth a
second-generation planet primed for life
you